on April 20th 1999 two gunmen killed 12
students and one teacher at Columbine
High School in Littleton Colorado Amy
over was a senior at Columbine Casey
Johnson and junior Tom mousers son
Daniel was a sophomore now nearly 20
years later we asked these members of
the Columbine community to reflect on
the two decades since the shooting in
notes to their younger selves
dear case dear Tom dear Amy you're 18
years old getting ready for senior prom
for the first time in your life you feel
confident you've overcome loss and
depression and are now starting your
junior year at a new high school you've
had a really good life a loving wife two
terrific kids you're so proud of them
you are not prepared what you're about
to face you will now mark all of your
life by what happened before and after
April 20th 1999 Tuesday morning you'll
meet with Dave Sanders your basketball
coach and mentor to discuss a college
scholarship offer he'll say you have so
much heart Amy I knew you could do it
instead of heading home for lunch as
always you will end up in the school
library two hours later you'll find
yourself hiding from gunshots under a
cafeteria table as you crouch and fear
with your classmates you see coach
telling us to run to get out as you look
back you will see your coach for the
last time school violence erupted again
today this time in Colorado you'll be at
work watching the news coverage the
shooting broke out just before lunch but
will be in denial that something bad
could happen to Daniel until hours pass
with no word from him big gun shot and a
teacher ran by you will hide under a
computer desk quietly pleading with God
to save you you'll simultaneously feel
that gut punch of evil as the shooters
enter the library and a strong invisible
hand on your shoulder providing an
unexplainable peace a slug from a
shotgun fired at close range will turn
the bones in your shoulder arm and hand
to
and burn a path across the front of your
throat you will have the clarity of mind
to slump down and pretend you are dead
coach Sanders and 12 students won't make
it out you'll get out safely your wounds
are invisible the day will stretch into
two as it will take nearly 24 hours to
be officially notified that your only
Son was one of the students killed you
will face a parent's worst nightmare the
loss of a child stay strong it won't be
easy you struggle in the aftermath
feeling guilty that you survived your
sense of safety and Trust has been
stolen from you you can't sit with your
back to an exit you fall to the ground
in fear when you hear loud noises now
you're the girl from Columbine broken
your coach is gone basketball isn't the
same and you're not the same trust your
gut get help start putting yourself back
together before you move on you will
find inspiration and Daniel you will
remember how he was so very shy yet
chose to join the debate team you will
start wearing his shoes to symbolize how
you two can overcome your shyness and
join this great debate about making
stronger gun laws we need to have change
that enough is enough
and I think we're gonna see Daniels wish
you will make sure the world remembers
the victims not the killers Daniel
Mauser was only 15 years old when he was
gunned down at Columbine she was an
amazing kid your survival will be
miraculous a team of doctors will create
a one-of-a-kind plan to use donated
cadaver bones to save your arm from
amputation still your now disabled body
and mind will cause pain PTSD and
paranoia you have thrived after
difficult circumstances before you can
do so again you'll have two beautiful
children and be married to the love of
your life he'll show you a path forward
even when you couldn't see one and
you'll walk it together the first time
you drop your daughter off at school
you'll have a panic attack fearing she
too will not be safe in the classroom
it's a chronic disorder you'll battle
for years tell your kids not to worry we
can't live our lives in fear you will
make Daniel proud adopting a baby girl
from China giving the time you would
have given to him to another child and
bring healing to your family you will
marry your prince charming and welcome
for beautiful babies into your family
on your story they'll travel around the
country share your story and help others
like the kids from parkland and Paducah
you will learn to use your story as a
public speaker and author to encourage
others and to advocate for bone and
tissue donation 20 years later you will
now face a painful anniversary this one
day is just so much more painful a day
you just can't wait to pass yeah you
will look back and be pleased with what
you've done to keep his memory alive
when you speak publicly you will wear
Daniels
old vans shoes the very ones he was
wearing on April 20th 1999 take solace
in the fact you will proudly walk in
Daniel Hughes for the rest of your life
[Music]
persevere ask for help and embrace love
and empathy it will allow you to move
beyond life's difficult moments and
reach the beautiful ones continue to be
brave choose freedom from fear do not
allow the troubles in your life to hold
your heart and mind the journey will be
tough but you will not only survive
you'll thrive Kirra cleveland produced
that piece along with a host of others
that was so beautifully done
we all remember Columbine at the time it
was so shocking and so unheard of
unfortunately it's we're not it's not
normal but we're no longer shocked by it
but it's good it's a good reminder of
what happened to people and how you get
through it and how you survive and how
sometimes you don't survive the part
that got me was Daniel wearing his sons
Tom wearing his son's shoes it's very
very very touching very moving and for
Casey and Tom and Amy who shared their
note to self with all of us it might be
one of the most powerful note to sell
sweep we've ever done it's hard to
believe it's been 20 I think so too
Nora and I remember it I know well I
remember and I can imagine April 20 if
he wanted to go from the 19th to the
21st let's just get through it but
you're right thank them all so much for
sharing their story no usually
beautifully done here thank you too